let's bring you some breaking news and
we're hearing that qter is currently
negotiating the release of between 10
and 15 captives being held in Gaza by
Hamas in return for a ceasefire that
would last for one or two days only four
captors have been released so far about
200 people have been held since October
the 7th so hearing that kater is
currently negotiating release of between
10 and 15 captives let's bring in my
jues wiy uh who's here to talk about
this director of studies Center the
studies Center at K University uh so
these negotiations have been going on
for some time but this seems to be a new
development I think um it was it was
announced by um Hamas I think in the
first week that or fers they want to
release them as early as possible and
they consider them guests when uh the
appropriate time is there and they
wanted to make sure that the roads are
safe and there's no bombard on on those
people and they want to make sure
because those people are not located in
one place they are it seems that they
are in different place and they want to
make sure they are you know and they can
move them to the safe place I think this
news uh is a greater news I think it
comes also after the the the
communication which were going on
between Washington and T Aviv in the
last 48 hours you know the vice
president of the United States has have
been talken to Netanyahu um Biden as
well uh his you know the director of the
CIA was in the region a few days ago I
think there was a a huge effort by the
Americans to uh having breaking through
when it comes to the uh hostages I think
this um few days ago there was an
attempt to release 12 people but there
was a complication on Logistics which
delayed the whole process if this
happens um because Hamas wanted a
ceasefire because they wanted to make
sure that food um and and need what
people need is coming in inside inside
coming into the Gaza so I think if this
if the hopefully it will go on uh that
will be a good start uh to uh you know
have a sort of a uh measures that can
facilitate releasing more of those
foreigners do you think do you think it
could come about because Israel of
course have said that they they don't
want a seesar or a PS of any kind I
think I think that's they couldn't
continue with this pressure it's obvious
um there are three elements now is
imposing on on Netanyahu government one
is the um international support is
actually is weakened because of all of
this massacr and number two there is a
pressure on the Western Government from
their own public opinion and the third
reason is uh there is a huge pressure
from within Israel for for how long they
will do this and now it seems the
narrative has been changed they wanted
to they start to look about on the
hostage Israelis and foreigners now it
seems they are dividing you know the
military people the Israeli are
different story but we need to make sure
that foreigners are released as soon as
possible
captives are a big element in this this
whole scenario and some two what two
weeks ago I think they were talking
about an all for all SWAP for these uh
for all the captives in Gaza and
potentially Palestinian prisoners in
Israel yeah and the and the the question
was you know what Israel will will will
pay back I mean because that you know
Palestinians they have request on the
table on the table they say okay we need
seiz fire we need we need ra to be open
we need to make sure that you know the
flood of uh water the of food medicine
is going on we need we need the bombard
of hospital to be stopped you know they
are request from the Palestinian as well
and and and I think I think this is an
indicator that Israelis has accepted
some of this because otherwise we would
not have this kind of Step It seems both
sides they came to the point that
everyone has to give some concession so
they make sure that things some relief
on the ground but it would seem that the
concession in this case would be a
ceasefire for one or two days would it
be anything more than that do you think
think for what are we talk about 10 and
15 capes it's a good start let's let's
remember in the first two weeks the
discussion was about 2 three hours the
discussion was is Cease Fire for two 3
hours 4 hours 6 hours now we talk about
48 hours and that's itself a good
achievement taking into consideration
the radical positions of Netanyahu
government what about the negotiating
team itself I mean Kat heavily involved
in all absolutely no doubt that qar has
a credibility when it comes to the issue
of mediation that Americans trusted them
they have made many many statements uh
showing the trust of the Qatari efforts
um and also uh Qatar said that you know
they have the office of Hamas in in DHA
as a a Channel of communication um and
they wanted to theq priority is
basically you know a ceasefire to stop
killing the civilians that's the
priority they want to see people you
know this ongoing killing in Gaza
stopped immediately and I I think that
is the message if this can save some
Life we'll be great or my we'll leave it
there for the moment we'll come back to
you later on this as as things develop
we will come back to it thanks a lot